with the elections just few days away
femi Claudius call is still in court
fighting her disqualification
the former presidential candidate and
high Unity party have been removed from
the ballot for reportedly not having an
office in each provinces required
an accusation she denies she said Sierra
Leone's male-dominated Society is not
making things easy for female
politicians despite the passage of
numerous laws the areas of the bill that
deals with politics and politicians and
women participating in politics all of
us
what they really mean is women should be
subdued
women should be calm women should know
their place that's the kind of women
they really want
there was widespread Jubilation when
Sierra Leone's parliament passed gender
Equity laws one of which demands women
should make up 30 percent of all
candidates running for any political
party
but freetown's former mayor and
candidate in next Saturday's vote said
despite the passage of the bill female
candidates are specifically targeted
the campaign is purely virtualic you
know so the cafe message is
she's Travelers total lie she's she's a
religious bigot again total lie
um it's a it's a campaign of hate
she says what will attract women to
politics is when they see how female
politicians are being treated for now he
says that picture is discouraging women
make up more than
half Sierra Leone and 52 of its
registered voters but only a small
fraction of them are represented in
public and private sectors but it's in
the political space that they are
especially marginalized despite this
numerical strength Ahmed Idris Al
Jazeera Freetown